Hales compress my name is today we're
gonna play agario and we're going to
destroy the leaderboard last time we got
ranked 10 on the first try so yes I do
think burning pooper no wait
the burning poopers cousin now wait
exploding nipples nipple nipple
exploding nip that is what it looks like
a nip will take over the servers and
everyone we will take over I don't know
why we did so well lifetime but I have a
great feeling about this brush this
little exploding nip is going to collect
a lot of a lot free hugs Wow
damnit you tricked me I don't think nice
guy is a nice guy either you need to
find like this area where for some
reason no one else goes to there is free
hugs he's do it using my tactic Hungary
don't make me laugh anyway Hungary is
making me hungry damn it free hugs is
doing better than me [ __ ] this marce
[ __ ] Harry Potter oh this is great
oh [ __ ] I'm somewhat ah exploding nap
now you [ __ ] you destroyed my other
nipple I will never forgive this game
really brings out my inner
twelve-year-old and that's how you know
it's a good [ __ ] you hungry
why did I do that I literally just set
out myself to die
good job pants you get it tempo [ __ ] you
exploding nipple will destroy you all
goddamn I piss now let's stop oh oh oh
oh oh it's not gonna be good for you
Mars is it snow it's gonna be good mate
[ __ ] got destroyed that's what I'm
talking about bridge high five
I'm Cupid to the plagues just have fun
my face yeah yeah
chi Chi Boy Ric NASA more like can I eat
you oh we're back in business baby
yes oh my god that was amazing
yes yes yes yes oh oh [ __ ] you know
straily I just went right in maybe Oh is
the FT he's afk mg one two three thank
you for the snack Brooke yes that is
right yo exploding nip went up to eat
exploded Nepal whoo-hoo-hoo
no no poor to go [ __ ] off eat a dick
nope nope bad portico bad portico ah no
no my exploding nipples will no one will
touch it oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] you oh he can't eat me ha exploding
in Polish seven Oh God we're so close
this is the greatest moment of my life
exploding nipple we'll take over the
world mark my words froze oh god oh god
this is really bad this is really bad I
don't know what the [ __ ] to do why are
you slowing down exploding nipple
now [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ]
all right we're fine we're fine we're
fine don't worry
we just dammit we lost our for its
eighth place [ __ ] hell
should we eat some testicles yes I think
yes thank you for the testicles number
six baby God too risky no no no you
again you I [ __ ] you assemble I had to
make a sacrifice dammit damn you fire
aah
this game is playing with my emotions
god damn it
it was going so well okay I want these
in my body right now did it you did it
you done [ __ ] up oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] no oh
we're the same size
testicles come here testicles I want you
inside me I don't know what's going on
right now but I don't [ __ ] like it oh
my god we made it out alive I don't know
how oh oh my god
aah exploding nipple exploding never Go
Go run for your life exploding nipple
free the nipple no explode the nipple
you got it wrong mate oh god yeah what
the [ __ ] was that oh my god you [ __ ]
me I can eat them I can eat them yes yes
Oh walk walk fresh breakfast [ __ ] I'm
number five
yes froze
I can't believe it come on oh-oh-oh-oh
number three just like that baby emoji
I'm gonna go pro one day Bruce I think
I'm gonna go MLG Pro it's happening it's
finally happening nom nom nom [ __ ] oh
here this here this this is what I
wanted this is what I wanted
come on come on come on come on come on
come on oh good ain't you gonna eat your
own damned yes yes no no no no no no